i really wanted to talk to you and make
sure that we discuss
um your amazing amazing
new show the animal rescue show
and i have more animals than
i i have a new segment on the show
called dr drew little
i mean i don't think there's ever a
better time
the shelters are cleared out people are
adopting left right and center
i think your show is so brilliant and so
timely
well this is and first off i want to say
that
an awful lot of brain power creative
creativity went into naming this show
the name of the show is that animal
rescue show
so i love it
[Laughter]
we didn't know what to call it so we
just called it that animal rescue show
because that's how everybody's going to
respond to it
this scene you're looking at right now
is really
indicative of the the plan of the show
this this turkey here uh
has one of its claws that is malformed
and you notice the little girl
has a hand that
was congenitally disfigured
and one of the things that we do in this
particular episode is
we have these animals that have either
been abused or
neglected or they were born with some
malady and we bring children out
with similar uh issues
and we have them relate to the animals
and
it is astounding
the bond that occurs between the
children
and the animals that have similar issues
we have children in wheelchairs and we
bring them out
and we have dogs and goats that are
in wheelchairs and they see the dogs and
the goats
that are so happy and so adapted and
playing and running and crashing into
each other
and the kids are like wow
they're so happy and they go
if they can be so happy i can be happy
and we with the turkey we call it her
special finn
and we say she has a special fin like
you do
and seeing what happens between the
animals and the children and how they
heal each other
is just so inspirational i can't even
begin to tell you
i think this show you know
really hearkens to a time where
we were able to speak to children
or adults in a really compassionate
empathetic uh you're not alone
here's how we cope and deal with all of
these
big things and this is this is
really substantive feel-good television
and i actually came home with two
puppies
uh i heard you adopted two dogs
oh my gosh and you know i had a rescue
uh that's them in the center there
waiting for me to come up from the
tennis court and they're just
so uh sweet and
i i had a rescue for 13 years that we
lost is one of the hardest things ever
and robin and i mourned the loss of
maggie for two years and then we ran
onto these two and and brought them home
so
uh we now have them and uh they're gonna
be big boys i think
i love like animals so much
and i just love that you got these dogs
and your new series
that animal rescue show premieres on cbs
all access tomorrow
and dr phil airs weekdays check your
local listings for more information
[Music]
you